[Música]
revista de prensa de hoy viernes 15 de
octubre con la señorita rosa pérez más
de borrosa bienvenida feliz viernes muy
buen día vamos a empezar hablando de
brasil con dos diarios primero vamos a
empezar con la carta capital hay
indicios de que evolucionar o cometió
genocidio contra indígenas dice la uap
la comisión de investigación
parlamentaria del cobi 19 empezamos con
este y luego desarrollamos el otro vale
rosa perfecto buenos días raúl nos hemos
querido fijar en este medio brasileño
carta capital que destaca en portada
precisamente esto que el consejo federal
del orden de abogados de brasil llevó un
escrito a la comisión parlamentaria del
senado de brasil que investiga la
gestión de la pandemia del gobierno de
bolsonaro y este consejo de abogados a
lo que alega en este escrito es que
persona lo podría haber cometido un
genocidio contra el pueblo indígena por
haberles negado ciertos suministros
básicos como sería agua potable y
equipamientos higiénicos o camas
hospitalarias y precisamente el orden de
abogados de brasil ante esta comisión
del senado
la descripción de genocidio que se
encuentra recogido en el tratado de roma
de la corte penal internacional y que
dice lo siguiente entre los escenarios
que contempla como genocidios dice la
intención de destruir un grupo nacional
étnico racial o religioso
entre otras cosas con la voluntad
expresa de imponer condiciones de vida
con el objetivo de causar su destrucción
física total o parcialmente vamos a ver
entonces cómo en este tema desde españa
vamos al diario punto es bolsonaro
acumula demandas ante la corte penal
internacional por no proteger la
amazonía
exacto de raúl en este caso el diario
punto es que es un medio independiente
español se fija en otra cosa acción
contra bolsonaro y en el hecho de que
acumula pues precisamente señalamientos
ante la corte penal internacional todas
tienen relación con supuestos crímenes
sociales pero este último ha señalado
por la organización austríaca alright
indica precisamente que bolsonaro podría
estar cometiendo crímenes de lesa
humanidad según esta organización porque
dice la actividad de deforestación que
está incentivando en el amazon ha
generado un aumento de la temperatura
global que podría terminar con la vida
de 180.000 personas en los próximos 80
años y precisamente pues el artículo
señala que ya van cuatro denuncias ante
esta corte internacional y que los
distintos a las distintas acusaciones
esperan que se estudien todas como un
mismo caso rózsa cambiamos ahora de
información vamos con nuestro tema del
día que precisamente estábamos
desarrollando con nuestra corresponsal
en roma natalia mendoza el corriere
della sera' el green paso obligatorio en
el trabajo desde hoy 15 de octubre
empiezan los controles y las protestas
rosa exacto este primer medio italiano
el corriere de la sera' está haciendo lo
que ya hemos visto en otros artículos
con otros temas y que se suele hacer
como una cobertura de una de una jornada
que es un live not destacando pues a los
puntos más importantes en cada momento
actualizándose cada 15 minutos y entre
otras cosas dice pues por ejemplo
bloqueo de las mercancías en el puerto
de génova manifestó estudiantil en la
universidad estatal de milán dice
también una cosa señalable control del
green pass de este pase sanitario
también en el consejo de ministros del
gobierno italiano bueno y señala todas
las otras movilizaciones en distintos
lugares de italia en florencia entre
este etcétera vamos a la república
precisamente rosa para hablar de esas
movilizaciones que usted estaba
adelantando de torino a roma es el día
de las manifestaciones contra este green
pas exacto este la república lo que
señala es más pues lo que puede
conllevar no todas estas movilizaciones
concretamente dice movilizaciones que
nos supone no están organizadas
alrededor de un cortejo único dice están
dispersas alrededor del territorio y
incluso dentro de la de las distintas
ciudades dice
centenares de iniciativas difíciles de
organizar fáciles de infiltrar y muy
complicadas de controlar precisamente se
remonta al sábado pasado cuando una
manifestación también masiva contra este
paso sanitario fue infiltrada no por
neofascistas del grupo fuerza nueva
asaltando la confederación italiana de
trabajadores todo este tema que ya
comentamos también entrevista de prensa
y que ahora está pues llevando al
gobierno italiano a estudiar la
ilegalización de este partido por
decreto dejamos un lado italia pero
seguimos en europa la unión europea
vámonos a españa canarias7 un sismo de
4.5 grados sacude la isla estamos
hablando por supuesto de la palma con
relación al volcán cumbre vieja rosa que
está que no para de echar la mano exacto
ya son más de 25 días desde que empezó
esta erupción y pues tal y como señala
este medio regional al que hemos acudido
distintas veces pues ya hay más de 7.000
personas desalojadas casi 700 hectáreas
pues devastadas por la lava y pues bueno
como señala los distintos puntos de
vista ha llegado a la palma un buque
cisterna que ha aportado el gobierno
central del gobierno de españa para
intentar salvar los cultivos que se han
quedado sin suministro de agua porque
pues es un sistema de regadío ha quedado
arrasado por la lava eso cuando los
cultivos no han sido directa arrasados
que también ha sido el caso de muchas de
plantaciones de bananos y si quieres
vamos a fijarnos en otro medio también
región en radiotelevisión canaria rosa y
se continúan las fusiones de lava que
alcanzan picos de gran velocidad exacto
pues allá es que el instituto
volcanológico de las islas canarias ha
calificado esta erupción de un tsunami
de lava no porque pues como comentábamos
ha sido unos días ya la lava destruyó el
cono no lo sobrepasó y precisamente en
radiotelevisión a canarias esta
televisión pública regional como hemos
comentado otras veces se puede hacer el
seguimiento de la erupción en este
momento y haber pedimos un momentito las
imágenes de nuevo porque hay un momento
bien impactante estas son imágenes de
anoche pero más adelante vemos porque
hemos grabado una parte de esta
retransmisión como la lava arrasa por
completo un campo de fútbol una iglesia
bueno son muchas las urbanizaciones que
han quedado arrasadas mira aquí vemos la
lava llega hasta la mitad del campo y se
lo acaba de comer todo pues es terrible
rosa lo que está pasando con el volcán
cumbre vieja en la isla de la palma
muchísimas gracias nos vemos el lunes
con más revista de prensa en directo
américa nosotros vamos con nuestro
primer invitado